all you do is go out Friday night of  course I'm going to go out you got a  nice girl I got a girl yeah nice a good  some of them are real nice do you think  he wants he wants to do I get your  number now Francesco is that your  Italian stallion I'm lucky Francesca  Francesca's my bad girl alias this  chicks you don't think you serious what  are you doing we were just uh doing a  radio so  [Music]  I'm so happy about you my god you so  what do you want to do with your life  really thought about it  these haven't been exposed I'm supposed  to work in the world  [Music]  I think she's keeping you around when  she goes back to her fancy ass College  in the fall we are having a summer fling  just on different traps you like the own  cars doing blow something new ballsy for  you you give me one hour I'll get you  the morning  [Music]  one  the boys doing hello mister pantagathus  we're just stealing your car  you  [Music]  you